chalon sur saône où son port sur la
saône tranquille avec ses rues d'autres
fois c'est place large ouverte aux
visiteurs ou commerces à la vie moderne
agité joyeuse de l'été chalon sur saône
vous ouvrira lé calme rue de son passé
si vous nous suivez vous qui êtes en
vacances vous monsieur madame
mademoiselle
alors arrêtez vous à sha lo et venez
visiter avec nous la vieille cité qui
est un monde à part admirer au passage
les fenêtres de la rue saint vincent qui
ont un air de bras sur l'essence
bourguignonne
sans oublier bien sûr la saône qui
arrache à l'eau on revient toujours à la
saône qui est le grand trait d'union
entre le passé et le présent
voici un tableau de l'époque louis xiv
avec l'hôpital au fond et la vieille
cité et devant l'église sainte marie qui
est un des bâtiments les plus anciens de
la ville monsieur armand callas
conservateur du musée de chalon comment
une visite de l'ancienne capitale des
pêcheurs et des marines
voici aux pierres de la super l'aérienne
beauté du cloître saint vincent du xvème
et xvième siècle la clau de l'évêché du
grand gardien bourguignonne la découpe à
jour et d'un merveilleux escalier de
bois la rue et 3 fait du jus de pomme
elle miro toujours la beauté d'une
vieille duo et la maison grillage et des
quatre saisons
sans oublier la complexité des victoires
qui donne tant de charme ou vieillir
essai
avec leurs fenêtres anciennes toujours
ouverte sur le plaisir et nous terminons
cette visite en contemplant la tow du
doyenné qui monte toujours la garde